we turn that to the thrill-seekers who
use snapchat to chronicle their climb of
the world's highest mountain they're
going back for more
Cory Richards and Adrian Ballinger gave
snapchat followers a percent account of
their Mount Everest adventure last year
Cory made it to Dutton through the top
but hypothermia forced Adrian to stop
just before the summit they're returning
this year to reach the peak together
they Bower is sponsoring the trip Cory
and Adrian are with us at the table but
first here's a look at last year's
incredible journey tense winds up you
know these mountains they break us they
bring us to the edge and finding without
edges and then figuring out if we can
still achieve beyond that and that's
what I love about this it's another
Hamelin sunrise I knew I was already
getting to that point where I wouldn't
be able to get myself down Alone's up to
me to hold it down that's the summit I
got to the top in about eight hours
I mean if Adrian had chosen to continue
we both would have had to turn around
when he got to a point where it was too
dangerous you know my success has always
been built on on partnership and and
this trip is I think the the prime
example of that in every way Cory
Richards and Adrian Ballinger welcome
thank you yeah I put things at the top
you say this is about Redemption do you
have a plan to be able to make it this
time that was not part of last year's
plan or was something you learned from
this year's trip or last year's trip
absolutely you know I came back from
last season and it took a few months to
sort of get back on track and be excited
again but by October of last of the last
year this has been my entire focus for
the past five months what do you do
different well I trained very
differently a much deeper trading with a
focus on low-level endurance I changed
my diet so I'm burning fats and
carbohydrates differently to be able to
have energy and warmth on the summit and
I think Cory and I were just really
focused on me having a clear head not a
lot of distractions this season so I can
focus on
the tactical plan is for me to go behind
him in push yeah yeah that's all I'm
telling you respect but how difficult
was it for you Adrian to make the
decision look I can't go forward cuz a
lot of guys would say I'm going to do it
and for you Cory to leave him behind and
keep going I mean for me it was it was
heartbreaking of course I've tried to do
this since I was 14 years old the scan
on top without oxygen and so in the big
picture is very difficult at the moment
that it happened there was no question I
was going to get myself killed up there
and so coming down was the right thing
to do you and Cory well I mean these are
like short-term marriages you know it's
all of the drama none of the benefits
though yes and to be fair I mean it's
really tragic when your partner turns
around I mean you've spent all this time
together building this anticipation and
then I mean it is heartbreaking so so I
mean there's real honest emotion going
back and trying to do this together as a
team but you know what else was
heartbreaking you getting right to the
tippy-top almost and then your friggin
battery died you don't snapchat from the
top we failed in our own I blew it
losers I'm a huge lighting the biggest
loser my friend I'm still working great
I just a smartest thing was your ability
to make a decision
there was a smart thing to do yeah it
really is given that you have limited
oxygen even at that level which impairs
your can impair your I think so much of
it falls back on sort of like all those
years and years of training and time in
the mountains that it's just clearly the
right thing to do even when you can't so
how are you changing your diet yes this
has been really interesting for me I
went and had some testing done and it
found that I've been just off sugars off
carbohydrates really well but above
25,000 feet you can't eat so you can't
put sugars into your body because you're
too nauseous usually and so I am on a
fully sort of paleo ketogenic diet no
call and what's the height there where
you are at the summit at the summit
29,000 field 4,000 more than 25 right so
for about 30 hours you're really not
putting anything into your body it's
just what you have what your system
burns
so I'm retraining my body to burn the
intramuscular fats we all carry and what
we learned I mean what I knew last year
from the testing that I did beforehand
what Adrien learned this year is that we
just have very different metabolisms
so he kick
and she starts burning intramuscular fat
very quick or I started burning
intramuscular fat and prefer it until
I'm at a very very high heart rate so
this is known for so sort of these
starts doing that around zone one and a
half - so that's why he's had to switch
his entire method of eating and training
were you guys always planning to do this
again are you doing it again because
both of you felt we didn't do what we
set out to accomplish we just like each
other there was no question we were
going to finish our romance it yeah this
is a bromance this is exactly what yeah
absolutely
there's no question this sort of forms
the whole year of what to train for what
I'm going to recover from and it was
clear is going to be Everest this path
something you want to engage more people
this time on snapchat right yeah well we
want to ratchet we want to use it more
as a viewer directed storytelling tool
so last year was all about us and
certainly we're going to keep that fun
element of you know two guys on Everest
doing this thing but we also want to
talk to the larger issues that are there
and engage the audience with and and say
well what do you want to know and
potentially use it as a sort of a social
hub so if classrooms want to follow us
we can take the questions that they're
asking and direct them and ask our
audience you know scientists and say
well what do you how do you answer this
question I can't wait where are you from
agent your accent is very interesting to
me is it announced America and then it
sounds something I'm a mud so I'm from
England originally was born there and
lived there until I was six years old
then I moved to Massachusetts very nice
I like it I just wash you could lock
them in yeah when you going when you go
in April 8th and when deployed get there
around the corner yeah right around the
corner we hope to summit at the end of
May Hey we'll be watching we're watching
and that take some haircare products we
love your support thank you so much
right
hair care products for you my friend so
nice and I'll be ready Cory Richards and
Adrian Ballinger thank you both